this is better I'm actually cut my
salary cheap I'm actually happy cut my
salary by 75%
but you money's not everything unless
you have a good yeah no I mean at the
end of the day Papa yeah again it's
Friday it's got Tokyo Friday
it's got hope your Friday we got our
boys we got a boy blue eyes
we got my capital Mike Catherwood my
fave
Stevie's in my face now I got good news
and bad news
yeah I woke up and I get a little tweet
from variety mag yeah you had your
picture I'm like oh hell yeah what was
in that's Joker to another cameo yeah
like yeah I do news madness good news
bad news
good news is you're gonna have more time
give more time to commit to firing the
kid yes and stand up yeah whatever else
you want to do all that stuff bad news
I need you down and you've been what
happened what happens you your spin-off
show school this cancer that's cancer
scare today wait a minute okay so my
show's been canceled because I take it
easy I don't want you to get all classy
fine you're fine I'm calm I'm gonna take
75% your salary I may have taken a 75%
salary cut do I have two mortgages yes
do I have a lot of other stuff like
alimony and child support of course I
hate to do more bad news
go ahead daliyah and I can't lend you
money and and this is where and this is
what's interesting about that comment
because I can force you guys to I said
that's Italy I just saw him this morning
I go hey I'll ruin you yeah your tags
are so funny like I start because I text
Brian I said I said on the article that
it's just getting canceled I go dude
sucks but he likes worse Italy and I
aren't gonna give any more money
no Brian replied you son of a [ __ ] as I
started doing this [ __ ] bit I'm not
good well I'm coming after you I think
you can physically for
Chris to give you money and Rob pretty
sure you have to stand no chance of
doing anything to Brendan no Papa got me
gonna get up no they it's ready though
I'm get my money wait and go with your
earned it Emily well I'm gonna be now
I'm not gonna podcast Monday oh my dad
yo see my mom is there ain't your show
just yet I know and then you're missing
this exact on Tuesday I'm gonna have to
replace already started don't face me
because I need my I need money now
oh yeah for your Monday did Kovac have
our audiences as well yeah
can we cut your audience cuz most most
viewing viewership went on say oh poor
daddy the belts gonna be a little tight
for a while at 53 daddy's got to tighten
his belt
I mean seasons in school we had to and
we were we did we were number two in the
ratings we were crushing the ratings and
they just I think it's two things it's
it's one is well no it's not two things
is one thing I think trying to get you
know production going with all these
ridiculous restrictions they don't know
how to do it insurance and everything so
especially not in LA just yeah they were
just like sorry look at this Adam
Goldberg 35 up now yeah 35 now now by
the way daddy used to be a pretty staple
on the Goldbergs Cole Brooks coming back
yeah make it a cop give me fine there
right yeah I might get a car why would
you want one car smell did they use the
same crew what's that did they just show
you the same go yeah maybe Spotify calls
us he gives us a hundred million dollars
yeah why not oh why not right why not if
I don't get what Rogen and make it gets
all the money and they can't [ __ ] in
they can't shovel over a little cash hey
that's not it that's not actually not a
bad point though because obviously Joe's
the guy who's opening the door but that
it's not gonna end and stop this right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
Oh